he would give anything to get me in a
pair of spanx that's all he ever wants
to do
let's serve up some news sunny side up
well first we're going to jump in the
tick-tock time machine going back to
the 90s apartment therapy reports that a
man in
iowa built a retro video
rental store in his basement and he
shared a tour on tick tock
it's not a business unfortunately we
can't go it's just a fun nostalgic
bunker for family and friends
he did it for his kids so i have to say
you know being inspired especially right
now when we're all stuck at home he gets
like
the father of the year award because
that is just so incredibly inventive
it's very cool and i would love to go in
and explore i missed
i missed like the blockbuster that kind
of store you know i would do like the
music store remember going to get a cd
oh of course i do by the way i used to
work at a music plus
when um yeah my boss was named whitney
he could not stand me
he was like a total hasher rocker he had
like the
he looked like frampton you know we have
a great story from the denim springs
louisiana
that shows why mom and pop shops are so
important to our communities
sunny skies reports that the owners of
poppy's fajita factory
have devised an easy way for customers
to help
the hungry and when you pay for your
meal you can buy a meal for someone else
at the very same time a coupon is
printed out and tacked to the wall and
anyone who needs it can take one of
those coupons as a voucher
and get a hot meal it's beautiful simple
easy way to take care of the people
around you
and i hope this practice spreads far and
wide saving the planet
and saving each other absolutely get
your fajita and give someone a free heda
that's right exactly right rossi i think
we have really good news today
well we've got a big debate that's got
the whole internet buzzing and talking
and it comes from the uk
entertainment weekly reports that the
sun published a story claiming the
world's sexiest bald man
is prince william and it was a part of a
survey where
mike tyson and jason statham came in
second
and third and the internet was
immediately up in arms there were calls
for like where is the rock
common ll but the fan favorite
i guess was like stanley tucci i get the
stanley tucci thing
because he's amazing i kind of forgot
about him for a little while until he
did that cnn show where he's cooking in
italy
oh i know i just want to go to italy now
i want to eat pasta he has a nice figure
too
and it's not an illusivious oh
whoa by the way i get jealous
i get jealous drew i get jealous well
gosh
you you are just a handsome man head to
toe
a show like bridger tin the steamy
netflix hit that broke records is coming
back for season two
it's been a personal favorite of mine
glamour reports that the show plans to
take some real-life inspiration from
former royals harry and megan
and in season two the characters simon
and daphne newlyweds
new parents will go through some
struggles similar to megan and harry
i think being royals having public
opinion
being new parents are sort of the
similar through lines
gail i can't think of anyone we've
looked to for the north star other than
you and oprah for
all of the truths from harry and megan
i think that interview opened up
conversations that many people weren't
prepared to have or didn't want to have
but i think ultimately it's it's about a
family that wants to be united and be
together and i'm hoping that that
that will be the case and have those
difficult conversations yes
yes i know sometimes conversations are
very difficult
yeah there's a 30 pair of
butt sculpting leggings that claim to
plump your rump
see some leggings are all the rage on
tick tock
number one on amazon's leggings for
women
and do they really yum your bum will
textile experts say
yes the secret is in the ruching
which is a special curved seam on the
back that makes your butt look curvier
ally i saw you working out on instagram
are you ready to juice that caboose or
what
i am not a girl who believes in all
those
uh smoke and mirrors my feeling is
this is what i got you know what i mean
i've been married for 100 years
i'm not going to make any secrets these
are real this is real nothing's padded
good night gracie you know lee harris
who is the
star brilliant stylist um i mean we're
just it's we're such good friends we've
worked together for 20 years
he would give anything to get me in a
pair of spanx that's all he ever wants
to do
is squeeze me into some tidy
shape-shifting forming things and i
won't do it that
poorly i'm sorry exactly
cheeky i really wanted to talk to you
about these books because you have six
children i do
these are really really cool books
because a kid's book about
creativity is something i would have
loved to have read
when i was young my books here in front
of me are a kid's book about bullying
a kid's book about create creativity a
kid's book about
gratitude all by three different authors
because we're not all experts in
everything you may be expert in one
thing
and can talk about it and tell stories
about it but not in everything and i
think that's
that's that's a beautiful thing because
it gives a way for
different people to express what they
want to get across to kids well and
listen to this list you have
death feminism disabilities money
body image divorce god coven 19
technology climate change
these are subjects we're all dealing
with these topics
are so critical i'm so in love with this
[Music]
series